GONG.
WELL.  FS SEARCHING FOR
S ASSAULTED AND D INWE ARE G
WARN YOUOPLE
TOK OF ATRUCK
IT IARE EN
P OFACROSS THEFRAYTHCRD NPOINT.
AUTHORITIES BELIEVE THAT THEY DE
THE U.R TOO
SA AINAN CITIZEN
WA KILLED.
CNN ROSES IS FOLLOWING
RO, AND E N PRESIDENT
AND AUTHIEYING TWERE NOT THE INE
FOCA
EXICO TEOPLE FROM
THEY CROSS TMEXICO FT THAT, FOLS
RESIDENT OF ,  SAY
CED
CONFRONTATION TH TWHEN
KIPENED.W,CCA U.
H KNIND MI TS
MEDICAL E  WASA
BASE REIE  C  TER TMED ER
WITHORE WHMI
ATW THAT VT WET
SHOWED YOUS
VERYTIC.
BEL IN WCHBECAUSE GRC.
ITNOCLR THESE
E INE
RED GUA OF PICKUP
E CA IAT THE NOT CONFIRM THATHE
RE IBUT
CNHAS CONFIR -- WITH A
U.S. OFFICIAWHHOTH THE
EXCUSE TH
HISIN DENE AND WE
GI
GIHE
AY INTENS
Y ENE.
TO THERICANS FE STTHDUALS ARE.
GH THERE IS A T ISN GOING